Chào cô bầu cử chủ tịch đang rất trụ tự gió ở lời đếp bê tâm quyền tại Nhật Bản.
Và đề người nước ngoài trở thành tâm điểm trên loạt,
cường tử viên đều đưa ra khổ yệu cướng sẵn, như hạn chế tiếp nhận,
khoảng 5 trạng nhập cửa thử pháp,
và nánh xếc cái tử dư lận sau cô bầu cử thử viện hồi tháng bầy,
khi đàn tham chính giành thêm phéo nhờ chủ trường,
người nhật trước tiền,
tuy nhiên Nhật Bản đứng trước hình lý khi vừa mũ sét quản lý,
vừa phải đối mặt với tình trạng kêu hủ t lo đọc nghiêm chào,
báo cáo hủ bụt thương pháp nhận bản tháng tham cho thấy
chính sách đối với người nước ngoài nhường nếu qua,
chỉ măng tình ứng phó, chưa có chế lực giải hạc,
hẹn xuống người nước ngoài cửa chú tình nhận bản đã lên tới gần bà vị tham chèo,
chế bà phần chăm xưa số,
tham chế vượt mười phân chăm tại một số địa vương,
trong bối cạnh đó,
tân chủ tình lợi đếp nếu cho thành thủ tử hong sế phay sư dựa một chính sách tân bằng,
bơ dưới chiều định sau hội và đếm hưởng yêu cầu kinh tế và nhận lực.